The construction industry
accounts for 30 to 40 percent
of the world's total energy and resources.
It also accounts for 40 percent
of the world's total carbon emissions.
A man who lived long before us
gave us a very simple solution.
And he is Mahatma Gandhi,
the father of our nation, India.
He said
that the ideal house should be built
with materials found in a five-mile
radius around the house.
So you think, OK, what is that material?
And it is right below our feet.
It's mud.
Now imagine, if we can build
a house with mud,
there would be nothing more sustainable
or eco-friendly than that.
But then, you might ask,
how strong is mud?
This compressed five percent
cement-added mud block,
made by my alma mater,
Auroville Earth Institute,
is twice as strong
as a country fired brick.
In fact, it has a dry compressive
strength of 6.5 megapascal,
as compared to a normal fired-brick,
which just has 3 to 3.5 megapascal.
But then you may again ask,
what about water?
Wouldn't water destroy mud brick?
This is a brick from the same institute
kept in water since 1995,
a little less than 30 years,
and you can see
that it can still hold
a significant amount of load.
So what does this tell us?
Can we change our perception
of construction?
Can we imagine a new way of building?
Or can we bring beauty to dirt?
I demoted myself from being
an architecture graduate
to being that of a mason.
Or maybe I promoted myself, I don't know.
I joined hands with local workers
and started teaching them mud techniques.
Very soon we started to change
every aspect of our construction.
Our foundations became poured earth
or rammed earth,
our walls became mud blocks
or compressed earth bricks.
Why, even our roofs became domes
and vaults made of mud bricks.
This is a brick wall residence
called Pirouette House,
which we made in a very crowded community.
So it goes in a zigzag pattern
in need of natural ventilation.
Now, please remember
that this wonderful parametric form,
or curves,
were made not with any
computational technology, AI
or robotic arms.
These were actually made
with coconut twigs, thread
and the masons' bear arms.
At a time when the building
industry is fast moving
towards a future that exceeds mankind,
we brought the value
of human resources back into it.
But way back in 2012,
I was posed with a very
life-altering question.
I was asked to build a residence,
a low-budget, eco-friendly residence
for a primary school teacher
called Biju Mathew.
And when I reached the site,
this was what I saw.
A mountain of waste and debris
dumped by the neighbors
after they finished their construction.
And because there was no other empty plot.
So what do I do?
Do I stand back and allow
this waste to be dumped elsewhere?
Or do I reimagine
the philosophy of building
with materials found in my vicinity?
Neither me nor the future
generations can unsee the waste
that is getting piled in our vicinity.
Therefore, we decided to use this waste
as a part of our construction technique.
We hand-pulverized this material,
added a bit of soil and again,
five-percent cement.
And using the techniques
we learned so far,
we kind of poured it in between two meshes
and poured the entire mixture into it.
The resultant product
was not just a formidable partition.
It was load-bearing,
means these walls
took the load
of the entire roof as well.
But this came at a price.
I was nicknamed “scrap engineer” by locals
who found it amusing to see an engineer
search through scrap in the junkyard.
But what I found
in the junkyard was pure gold:
this is discarded electric meter boxes,
washing machine wheels,
decaying wood, all became part
of a new philosophy
that included more and more waste.
Thank you.
(Applause)
Now, emboldened by this,
our new aim was to build
multi-storied mud and waste construction.
Is that possible? Yes.
This is Shikhara, a three-storeyed
multi-story, mud and waste construction.
We decided to further modify
what we did in the Biju Mathew residence.
So instead of using two meshes,
we put two wooden shutters
and poured the same mixture
which we did in the earlier project.
And the resultant product
was as strong as before
and economical too.
This wall had a dry compressive
strength of 4.5 megapascal.
And mind you, this building,
this residence,
we completed in a meager budget
of 90,000 dollars
as compared to a general budget
of 200,000 dollars or more.
Very soon --
(Applause)
Very soon, many practices in the country
started adopting this technique,
not just because of its eco-friendly part,
but also because it was cost-effective.
For us Indians,
born to traditional societies,
very often, our dreams culminate
in lavish weddings and festivals.
This, by the way, is a wedding stage.
But the very next day,
this too, is a common scene.
India discards 3.6 million tons of plastic
every year.
Therefore, we decided
to utilize plastic bottles
as a part of our construction
for a new project called Chuzhi.
It's a housing project.
And in this project,
we started to build circular beams
using plastic bottles and reinforced
concrete and of course, mud.
We started to build it in circles.
To be honest, we didn’t know
how this would eventually look,
but we still kept on building the circles.
(Laughter)
We made it stable
and put a roof on top of it.
You can see how weird this looks.
Chuzhi is a project
that resides in a rocky terrain.
And it's populated
by a lot of trees and shrubs.
Now, generally,
these two factors are attributed
as very bad things for construction.
People generally cut trees
or clear them to make spaces for their
rooms or buildings or whatever.
But in here,
the trees not only form shelter
but also cool the building
in a tropical climate.
And as far as the terrain was concerned,
generally, people would fill it up,
level it, clear it
and build on top of it.
But here,
the building is perfectly camouflaged
in the rocky terrain,
that 10 metres away from this project,
you will not see it.
That is how good it is camouflaged.
In this project --
(Applause)
We managed to use 4,300 plastic bottles
which would have otherwise
ended up as a landfill
or even worse, in the ocean.
One day, we all got sick
working at the site.
We had breathing difficulty
and we kind of went to the doctor.
And the doctor very calmly said,
"Ah, it must be the burning tires
used in road construction.
Stay away."
And we were shocked.
There are hundreds of kids
who travel these roads
every day to their schools.
There are thousands of families
who traverse these roads
every day to their jobs,
why some of us even stay on these roads.
And the answer is stay away.
Upon further investigation,
adding to our worst nightmare,
we found out that our country discards
half a million tires in a day.
(Audience murmurs)
No, no, I'm not done yet.
And the rest of the world discards
another half a million tires
to India on the same day.
(Audience murmurs)
Yeah.
This is an aerial pic of a tire dump,
seen from space.
This is in a GCC country,
that collects the tires
from all of you guys,
and eventually, dumps it
in countries like India.
Now you should remember,
all of these tires, most of them at least,
eventually end up either
in the road tarring illegal process
or we end up burning it
to make again fuel oil,
because this is a petroleum product.
Now, one way to neutralize
this huge toxic threat
is to use it as part of construction.
Now inspired from architects
like Michael Reynolds,
we introduced mud and tire
to form a new building
construction technique.
And now we are building residences,
we are building museums, schools.
And this is the best way
to neutralize this threat
and create beautiful construction.
We believe that tomorrow this may also be
the alternative for the housing crisis
that is a big reality
for many of our underdeveloped countries.
The heart of every project of ours
lies with the problems
that we created amongst us.
Discarded tires,
plastic bottles,
construction debris.
None of these things
should be dumped thoughtlessly
or carelessly.
The world can not just find a solution,
but we can even find beauty
in this disaster
that we created for ourselves.
I remember a single line
by the poet of my native language, Ulloor,
and it goes like this.
(Speaking Malayalam)
And it translates to this:
It is our choice
whether to build heaven or hell on Earth.
Thank you, thank you.
(Applause and cheers)